heute ist kein normaler tag heute ist
der geburtstag von meiner kleinen
schwester ich weiß nicht ob wir das alle
wussten aber ich habe mein bruder und
meine kleine schwester die nicht auf
youtube ist und ein guter bruder wie ich
bin habe ich mir natürlich ein geschenk
für sie überlegt und das geschenk ist
dass wir zusammen nach frankfurt in die
innenstadt fahren und sie den ganzen tag
lang von mir bekommt und ich mache was
sie will ja also das wird dieses video
wir fahren nach frankfurt und ich würde
wahrscheinlich irgendwelche dummen
sachen machen müssen ich selbst so viel
geld ausgeben und es wird lustig meine
kleine schwester wird hinter der kamera
sein und mir dann halt immer sagen was
ich mache und ja dann würde ich sagen
beginnen wir mit dem längsten spaß und
ab geht's okay die wollen wir das
überhaupt machen kannst deinen namen
sagen den ganzen tag eure meisten leute
nichts gehört und er nicht ihr tag ist
etwas kaufen muss
mit zum beispiel kaugummi gegen den
kaffee probieren einzukaufen
diese verkäufer so ansprechend wie ich
will
gib mir dein geld machen
kaufen sie ihn selbst oder solchen
kaufen nido nach kaarst allerdings musst
du nicht nach einem donut fragen wunder
sagen wir mal nach einem runden teilchen
mit einem loch von e
doch bis zwölf warum machst du so
schreckliche dinge über dich mein
geburtstag haben sich die runden
teilchen mit dem loch in der mitte
die
zufrieden eure majestät nachsehen
liebevolle zukunft
die leute hier und das bringt auf den
boden
traden der saal füllt wasser knie boll
knie beugen
also meine kleine schwester wird mir
heute komplett zum affen machen
wahrscheinlich in frankfurt ja lustig
übrigens es wird allmählich jetzt schon
draußen dunkel
das signal das man schwester lang in der
schule war und danach wollte sie erst
mal ein bisschen minecraft auf meinem pc
spielen das unterstütze ich
harry potters sehr akzeptiert was willst
du weißt du schon ein bisschen mehr
gucken wir sind dann auf dem weg zur
zeit übrigens leute filmabend zumal mit
meinem handy dass sich die große kammer
rausholen muss
wer nicht immer so das allerbeste und
schleifte in frankfurt mit seiner kamera
aufzulaufen
wir laufen zur zeit später können auf
dem weihnachtsmarkt und so sieht der
plan bisher aus wenn jetzt alle erstes
zu ende
ok
[Musik]
ja
weil du mir die ganze zeit was gekauft
hast zum essen darf sich mehr
du kannst auch mal was essen die bonität
ja
die slacker okay
zufrieden nein mehr bis zu dem moment
kommt jetzt auch noch unser papa zu uns
nach frankfurt und den suchen wir gerade
wenn man sich an der hauptwache
verabredet und dann geht es endlich zu
elbenwald in der eure majestät eure
majestät mein papa und ich haben
zusammen gefunden und jetzt soll es erst
mal essen gehen oder vielleicht
vielleicht hört befindet sich schon
einen keks im mund der majestät ich
spiele gerne mit dem feuer und den
wellen
[Musik]
und danach was zu essen
ich weiß nicht vom baum
du kannst du gleich neben klassik besser
aus als mittel höher ist gesagt lass mir
die stadt von der mine geschickt
fleximer damit
flex immer so liegen sind sie mit dem
bisherigen geschenken zufrieden und dem
bisherigen tag eure majestät mehr als
sehr eigentlich
langsam aber sicher werde ich alle leute
der euro steht ja wir sind auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt angekommen und
wie ihr vielleicht mitbekommen habt wird
heute viel gegessen und auch jetzt
werden wir wieder essen und zwar
flammkuchen die sind so gut auf dem
frankfurter weihnachtsmarkt job gesehen
[Musik]
mit mir jetzt auf dem karussell der
freunde um die wette reise ist für
kinder kamen
[Musik]
ich verstehe sehr links erst seine augen
richtig beleuchtet
leute ich bin gerade am schnitt vom
video und ich bin so ko ich weiß nicht
woran das liegt also ich hab heute
nachher nicht so viel geschlafen weil
ich damit mit meiner mutter und meiner
schwester so kuchen und singen und
sonstwas morgens damit hier gut den
geburtstag kommt machen kann auf jeden
fall bin ich jetzt so hart ko und das
video konnte ich das auch nicht so krass
bearbeiten aber ich wollte unbedingt
heute noch ein video raus haben weil
jetzt nicht einfach so krass supported
die letzten tage dass ich jetzt nicht
ein tag ohne video davon wollte sag ich
mal
und ich hoffe sehr dass euch das video
gefallen hat so im schnitt ich meine das
ist jetzt halt nicht so spektakulär ist
sage ich mal wie wenn ich eine kranke
challenge mit sebastian oder luca mache
oder so aber es liegt auch daran dass
meine kleine schwester 12 ist und sich
nicht so sachen aus dem aus der nase
zieht wie keine ahnung geht zu
irgendeinem passanten und tippen auf die
schulter oder so also passiert halt vor
allem das ganze ausgenutzt damit ich ihr
ihr lieblingsessen kaufe naja ich hoffe
mal das video ich trotzdem gefallen
morgen gibt es ein fettes super-mario
run video also freut euch da auf jeden
fall drauf das wird der hammer
und ja da würde ich sagen sie wir uns
morgen danke fürs zu sehen
danke für den support für mich sehr
freuen wenn ihren like dallas und falls
ich mein letztes video aus checken wollt
dann könnt ihr das gerne tun und dann
sehen wir zunächst mal wieder macht's
gut und tschüss